last week AMD launched two new graphics
cards the Radeon RX 7800 XT and the
rx7700 XT and so far the overall
consensus seems to be that the 7800 XT
is quite great but the 7700 XT is just
now worth considering because it is much
slower but not a much cheaper than its
bigger brother and now which is less
than a week later the price of the RX
7700 XT is already going down now it
will depend a bit on the region but here
in the Netherlands for example some
models are already being sold for 20 to
30 Euros under the MSRP and some of the
premium models like this gigabyte gamigo
C for example are being sold for that
base 509 Euro MSRP which makes it
slightly bit more interesting than it
was before so let's see how it performs
in 33 different games on three different
resolutions how it compares to the 7800
XT and let's see if and when it makes
sense to actually buy this card so let's
begin looking at the specs we can
already see why the 7700 XT doesn't seem
that sensible the core count does scale
with the recommended price difference
and the 7700 XT does have slightly
better clock speeds than the 7800 XT but
you also get 25 less memory and the
effective memory speed is lower as well
and I think the biggest problem here is
that 50 difference it is just not that
much on a 500 card I mean it might be a
bigger deal if you're comparing a 200
and a 250 dollar card for example but
just not in this price bracket since the
reference card doesn't exist we tested
this gigabyte gaming OC model right here
it is a large three fan card that is
almost three slots thick and it just
looks and feels very sturdy and
relatively impressive with its size but
it is also a car that comes with a
decent Factory overclock so do keep that
in mind I will also include some data of
the 7 7800 XT gaming OC to keep the
perspective Fair because the gigabyte
model is faster than the reference AMD
model and other than that this card also
uses two regular eight pin power
connectors it has a fan stop feature
dual bios switch and it offers two HDMI
2.1 connections and two display port 2.1
connections as well but let's see how it
performs when it comes to gaming and
let's start with Baldur's Gate 3 which
is a fantastic game and you should
absolutely give it a go if you haven't
played it already on 1080p resolution
and ultra settings the 7700 XT roughly
matches the other card so we seem to be
running into a CPU bottleneck although
it does have better one percent lows
than the 8 gigabyte RTX 4060 TI on 1440p
the 7700 XT does drop a bit below the
7800 XT and the one percent lows dropped
below 60fps but I would say it still
holds up relatively well Starfield is an
AMD feature title and you can really see
that in the results as it even manages
to just be the much more expensive RTX
4070 at both 1080P and 1440p resolutions
but the RX 7800 XT performs a lot better
here now I am testing this in a city
environment so performance is a bit
worse than other parts of the game and
since Starfield is only just out we
should expect some performance patches
in the next few weeks and these numbers
might end up being completely different
Remnant 2 is another new title that came
out a few weeks ago and here the 7700 XT
looks pretty good as well easily beating
the RTX 46 CTI on both resolutions and
even competing with the RTX 4070 at
1440p in Microsoft flight simulator the
7700 XT holds up well especially on
1440p resolution where the RTX 46 CTI
really starts to suffer but again the
7800 XT does show much better numbers
for that small price difference in
Spider-Man remastered the Nvidia usually
does a bit better and here the 7700 XT
dropped just under the RTX 4060 TI and
the 7800 XT is well ahead still it plays
the game great even on 1440p God of War
generally works better for AMD and here
the 7700 XT ends up between the 4060 TI
and the RTX 4070 on both resolutions
with the 7800 XT being ahead again
Assassin's Creed Valhalla is an AMD
sponsored title and it ends up looking
similar to God of War with the 7700 XT
in between the 4060 TI and the 4070 with
the 7800 XT ahead by quite a lot Dying
Light 2 on the other hand is an Nvidia
sponsor title but that isn't enough to
keep the 7 700 XT from beating the 4060
TI yet again and it is the same in
cyberpunk 2077. it is an Nvidia
sponsored title and generally it is a
game where we see Nvidia gpus outperform
their AMD counterparts but the rx7700 XT
still holds up well compared to the RTX
460 TI even if the 7800 XT offers a much
better experience especially on 1440p
resolution Doom Eternal is a super easy
game to run that scales well with GPU
performance and as always pretty much
every recent GPU will run this smoothly
on any resolution and here the 7700 XT
isn't even that far from the 7800 XT
with the RTX 4060 TI falling well behind
Formula 1 2022 on ultra high settings
which includes some Ray tracing effects
is a good example of why you might want
a bit more power than these 7700 XD has
to offer if it doesn't cost too much the
7700 XT is fine but the 7800 XT is
noticeably better now to keep it a bit
shorter I'm not going to talk about
every single individual game so let's
look at some summaries instead on 1080p
the 7700 XT will generally get you 100
FPS or more in most games sometimes a
bit less if you crank everything to
ultra like in Red Dead Redemption 2 or
if you run into CPU bottlenecks like in
Starfield or Microsoft flight simulator
but it still handles every game easily
with even some Headroom to spare on
1440p we do end up with an average of 60
FPS or more in every game tested but
several games do show that on this
resolution you don't have that much
Headroom to spare of course many games
nowadays feature FSR upscaling and
alternatively you can drop your graphic
settings to Media em as well like I said
in my 7800 XT review it is not a 4K card
and the same goes for the 7700 XD it
really starts to struggle here and while
FSR will manage to help in a lot of
games it won't help in every single
title so if you're okay with 30 FPS
instead of 60 and if you're okay with
upscaling and dropping settings in most
heavier games you can get this to work
on a 4K resolution I guess but as you
can see here the only slightly more
expensive 7800 XT just looks much much
better so the obvious problem for the
7700 XT is clearly the 7800 XT so if we
compare the gigabyte gaminggo C version
of both the 7800 XT is 17 faster on
1080p 22 faster on 1440p and 25 faster
on 4K resolution and the 50 difference
in price we see in the US which makes
the 7800 XT 11 more expensive just isn't
nearly enough to justify the 7700 XT in
any possible way and even with a price
drop here in the Netherlands I still
don't think it is good enough the 7800
XT costs about 16 more but I think it's
worth paying 80 Euros extra for a solid
22 more performance on 1440p and 4
gigabytes of extra vram because that
will make a difference in the years to
come so so the question is what the 7700
XT should cost in order to make sense
which can also kind of depend on where
you live and how much you pay for
electricity because AMD is a lot less
efficient than Nvidia the gigabyte 7800
XT uses about 44 Watts or 18 more power
to give you that 22 more performance and
this overclocked 7700 XT card is close
to the reference 7800 XT model while
being considerably slower it also means
that this 7700 XT uses more power than a
much faster RTX 4070 does and it uses
over 60 percent more power than the RTX
4060 TI and while the 4060 TI gets a lot
of criticism and it really deserves it
in my opinion especially at 400 that
power difference can really start to add
up depending on how much you pay for
power and how much you gain per day if
if your power is very cheap and you
don't gain a crazy amount it won't
really matter that much even with a
relatively large power difference
between these cards but with more game
hours per day and with some rates that
we pay here in Europe for example gaming
on a 7700 XT can actually end up costing
you hundreds of Euros more over a three
to four year period the 7700 XT is about
15 faster than the 4060 TI on 1080P and
22 faster on 1440p which is a big
performance difference but it's 64
percent of higher power draw you cannot
ride the RTX 46 CTI off as an
alternative and the fact that it can
make the 4060 TI look slightly more
reasonable than it was before just says
a lot about this card so in the end if
you're in a place where power is cheap
and it just isn't a concern for you you
can consider a 7700 XT but only if it
costs about 400 or less so it needs to
be at least 100 cheaper than the 7800 XT
to make sense in my opinion and even
then a 7800 XT would still be a nicer
choice for anyone that can afford to
spend a bit more to get one for those of
you that live in a place where power is
quite expensive like here in the
Netherlands for example I'm just not
really sure that gigabyte or AMD can do
enough to make this 7700 XT make any
sense or at least not in the short run
the price drops so far are very nice but
not nearly enough in my opinion it needs
to be at least 100 euros less than it
costs right now to make any sense and
I'm not sure that will really happen
anywhere in the near future that being
said it is also not impossible because
it has has been less than a week and
prices are already dropping and AMD does
have a history of aggressive price drops
if supply and demand require it so it is
definitely a possibility and I really
recommend you keep an eye on those
prices and make your total power cost
calculation before making your choice
this video was brought to you by Corsair
and their Elite LCD XD coolers these
Premium All-In-One water coolers combine
excellent performance with a fully
customizable LCD screen that can
showcase anything you have in mind with
a low noise pump and the AF Elite fans
they can easily keep up with the latest
and hottest of processors out there
while keeping your system quiet you can
install them on a variety of sockets
including the latest Intel and AMD ones
and once the installation is complete
you can use the IQ software to control
the RGB effects or sync them with the
rest of your Corsair gear check them out
using the links in the description below
I hope you enjoyed this video and I hope
it was helpful at least just a bit if
you liked it do consider clicking that
subscribe button so you don't miss my
future uploads thank you all for
watching and I will see you in the next
one bye